bonsoir à tous
à tous quel plaisir de voir aussi
nombreuses et nombreux alors en
préparant mon intervention je me suis
dit que ça c'est sympa pour illustrer
mon parcours de vous montrer une photo
de moi en train de faire de la recherche
et je suis tombé sur celle là qu'est qui
a été prise en décembre 2003 le jour de
ma soutenance de thèse en biologie de la
peau alors puisqu'on entre nous je vous
avouer que j'ai quand même hésité un
moment vous la montrer mais pas pour ce
que vous croyez
non en fait j'ai quelque chose qui met
mal à l'aise dans cette photo mais en
même temps elle explique tellement bien
à gilles dussault tellement bien ce qui
va emmener par la suite à développer ce
que j'appelais l'intelligence personnel
et dont on va parler que je suis allée
va-t-il ans touazi fait montre là alors
qu'est ce qui m'a gêné dans cette image
non si vous êtes par les avais pensé que
c'est ma coupe de cheveux c'est pas très
gentil parce que j'ai exactement la même
aujourd'hui
non plus sérieusement quand je regarde
cette photo ce qui met mal à l'aise
c'est le contraste entre mon sourire et
de souvenirs que j'ai de ce que je
vivais à cette époque là à cette époque
là en effet c'est environ quinze ans que
je souffrais en quasi-permanence
d'agoraphobie vous savez cette peur des
grands espaces et de la foule alors
évidemment quand on parle de souffrance
ya toujours pire hein mais vécue au
quotidien je vois pas vraiment d'autres
mots pour l'expliquer imaginez par
exemple qu'au lieu de remercier un ami
qui a vraiment la gentillesse vous
porter les cours que vous avez raté à la
fac voulu supplié à travers l'apport de
pas rentrer dans la pièce pour pas subir
de nouveaux symptômes ou aux mazilles
imagina encore que le simple fait de
traverser le couloir sur son palier pour
chercher son courrier ou par est plus
difficile que de courir le marathon de
new york
alors évidemment il y avait des hauts et
des bas léo permettant de faire à peu
près comme toulon les piles et bab et
attend que ça passe
surtout en espérant que ça passe alors
balader de médecin en médecin exams en
tous genres électro cardiogramme
électroencéphalogramme électro
machinchose la médecine étant incapable
de trouver ce que j'avais le diagnostic
était tombé c'est dans votre tête
monsieur pommery dans ma tête mais rien
dans ma tête
et evs est effectivement pour moi je
n'étais pas malade
la maladie est uniquement mes symptômes
une sensation d'ébriété en permanence
bas qui faisait que dans les soirées
quand je refuse un verre d'alcool je
passais pour quelqu'un de 13 13 le
vertueux de très sobre non merci j'en ai
pas besoin comme obélix je suis tombé
dedans quand j'étais petit bref perte de
la vision sensation de mourir que des
choses super agréable mais ma tête elle
allait très bien toujours dans les
premiers de la classe major de dieu a la
meilleure mention pour le doctorat avec
les félicitations du jury en plus alors
qu'est-ce qui tournait pas rond dans ma
tête j'ai compris qu'il s'agissait d'un
problème s'il s'agissait au problème de
traitement de l'information
vous allez c'est signe qu'on capte en
permanence ce traitement suis toujours
ce schéma la réception de l'information
à la liste de l'information prise de
décision action et parfois notre analyse
de l'information nous pousse à prendre
des décisions mais totalement absurde
contre nos propres intérêts données se
reprend l'exemple des phobies quand se
fige devant une araignée de 20 cm
d'envergure ça peut paraître normal on
peut ses remords dépit bon faut dire
qu'on n'est pas non plus l'habitude de
voir ça tous les jours
aller mais franchement entre nous quitte
à renier des quelques millimètres c'est
ridicule bah allez dire ça à un
arachnophobes il le sait que l'araignée
plus rien lui faire c'est même plutôt le
contraire
mais son système interne d'analysé de
l'information lui donne une mauvaise
interprétation de l'information et va le
mettre en panique alors du coup il ya
d'autres
d'autres anecdotes qui sont qui sont
intervenus ils ont alimenté tout ça un
autre exemple dans mon bonhomme en
doctorat grosse panique parce que vous
savez on n'a que trois ans pour faire sa
thèse
et puis ça faisait des mois que
j'arrivais pas à avancer je galérais
j'arrivais pas à mettre en culture des
kératinocytes primaire des fibroblastes
de souris dans du milieu des mêmes n'en
attendait pourtant c'était facile
il suffisait de qualité le sérum de vaud
foetale pour diminuer la concentration
des ions ca plus plus et d enrichir le
milieu mais oui bien sûr non c'est pas
ça le problème problème c'est que malgré
que cette information était connu dans
laboratoire et qu'on se dit
régulièrement des réunions pour parler
de nos problèmes
il a fallu que j'en parle par hasard
devant la machine à café à un collègue
pour avoir la réponse
et c'est finalement ça qui m'a paru
comme très important pour faire avancer
la recherche
comment trouver rapidement des remèdes
aux maladies
si on n'est pas capables nous mêmes dans
laboratoire d'organiser nos
connaissances notre mémoire et qu'on
passe notre temps à réinventer la roue
en me renseignant un peu j'ai appris que
gérer l'information et gérer les
connaissances ça pourrait apprendre et
qu'elle même des gens qui avaient
travaillé sur le sujet dans le domaine
économique et des entreprises et caves
appeler ça attention gros mot
l'intelligence économique
alors de quoi s'agit-il l'indigence
économique va permettre par la maîtrise
de l'information être plus compétitive
plus performant ça sert aux entreprises
aux associations aux ong aux arts etc
et ça passe par trois étapes
essentielles la recherche la collecte
l'analyse la diffusion de l'information
dans mon métier on appelle ça faire de
la veille quand il s'agit non pas
l'information mais les connaissances on
parle de management des connaissances
le deuxième volet c'est la sécurité la
protection des biens matériels et
immatériels son savoir-faire ses
connaissances ses connaissances son
patrimoine est le troisième volet
l'influencent alors d'un peu de
communication arriver à convaincre les
autres mais aussi d'un point de vue
normatif pour rendre l'environnement
plus propice à son développement
alors évidemment tout ça s'est fait de
manière légale en parle pas d'espionnage
d'une manipulation comme on l'entend
d'ailleurs malheureusement parfois dans
les médias un exemple une petite
entreprise dont la qualité des produits
pas être critiqués sur internet de
manière injuste et anonyme
le chef d'entreprise déjà besoin de
réagir au plus vite donc pour ça il faut
qu'ils détectent l'information
c'est grâce à la veille il va falloir
qu'il se donne une bonne réputation donc
il communique ses l'influencent et tout
ça c'est pourquoi mais c'est pour
protéger son patrimoine protégé ses
emplois dans l'entreprise alors les
entreprises ont maintenant des outils
pour bien gérer l'information parce que
forcément avec un petit peu d'argent en
jeu et beaucoup de choses qui peuvent se
développer
mais que se passe-t-il pour les
individus comment on leur apprend les
individus âgés à gérer l'information au
quotidien
est ce que par exemple vous pensez que
les cornes apprend bien recherché de
l'information sur internet à vos enfants
vous toutes et la réponse est ce que
vous pensez que les adolescents savent
comment se protéger et comment réagir en
cas de rumeurs sur facebook ses limites
et vous est ce que vous seriez le faire
est ce que vous seriez la prendre à vos
enfants ou même à vos parents car les
seniors aussi sont concernés en vie plus
longtemps et c'est tant mieux et de
manière autonome et c'est encore tant
mieux et il ya de plus en plus de sites
web qui est qu'ils sont destinés aux
seniors mais est-ce que les seniors ça
vraiment les identifier ces sites est
utilisé je parle même pas d'utiliser
correctement un ordinateur rick
malheureusement on n'est pas nombreux à
pouvoir répondre oui à toutes ces
questions
alors certains alors pourquoi pourquoi
on peut pas répondre à ces questions
tout simplement parce que quand c'est
évident on pense pas nous l'apprendre ou
même pire on n'a même pas conscience
qu'ils sont importants nous l'apprend
alors certes un concept conscience la
seconde se met se rentre dans des
démarches de développement personnel et
c'est très bien si ce n'est qu'il
n'existe pas de méthode
j'insiste homo méthode de développement
personnel qui permet de bien gérer
toutes ces questions là sous le prisme
de l'âge des associations de
l'information mais qui est pas de
méthode finalement c'est pas très grave
pourquoi cas comme le disait emerson
l'homme qui comprend les principes peut
choisir ses propres méthodes avec succès
ce qui est important c'est pas les
méthodes comment on fait les choses
qu'ils ne lancent ils comprendre les
grands principes pourquoi on fait les
choses
une fois qu'on a compris pourquoi c'est
beau fils c'est beaucoup plus facile de
développer ses propres méthodes et bien
alors je me suis demandé mais comment
quelles peuvent être ses grands
principes qui pourraient aider les
individus au quotidien à mieux gérer des
informations
et je suis partie des travaux d'abraham
a selon un psychologue américain qui
dans les années 40
nous a donné nous a éclairés sur les
grandes étapes à suivre pour nous
épanouir en travaillant sur la
motivation
il a identifié cinq grands besoins à
sous-virer sont tout un art dans lequel
enchaîné ses besoins mais pense épanouir
le premier besoin c'est le besoin
physiologique respirer manger boire et
plus si affinités je vous laisse faire
le support le deuxième besoin le besoin
de sécurité
avoir un environnement stable prévisible
puis arrive le besoin d'appartenance
rechercher l'amour de l'affection des
autres dans l'ordre le besoin d' estime
le respect de soi la reconnaissance et
l'appréciation des autres et puis tout
en raw arrive le besoin
d'accomplissement de soi le sentiment
d'avoir accompli un but dans sa vie donc
maclou nous dit qu'on ne peut
normalement générale or il ya des
exceptions on ne va pas s'intéresser un
besoin supérieur en haut de cette
structure tant qu'on n'a pas sauvé ses
besoins plus inférieur évidemment
quelqu'un qui avant de se préoccuper la
reconnaissance et la prestation des
autres une tête mieux d'abord avoir
mangé dormi être en pleine forme on est
bien d'accord et je suis partie de ces
cinq principes là pour développer les
cinq grands principes de ce que j'ai
appelé n'ont pas l'intelligence
économique personnelle mais tout
simplement l'intelligence personnel
si ce n'est que dans l'intelligence
personnel nos besoins physiologiques ne
sont pas de manger de boire de respirer
mais notre alimentation en informations
ainsi le premier besoins essentiels et
la recherche d'informations et la veille
apprendre à rechercher l'information
utile la bonne information dans un
environnement justement sur saturant
l'information va nous permettre de faire
de meilleurs choix c'est-à-dire ce qui
correspond à nos valeurs
ce qu'on aura le moins de chances entre
guillemets de regretter par la suite par
la recherche d'informations quant à la
maîtrise en identifier ce que font de
bien les autres pour pour le faire nous
mêmes les erreurs à éviter pour pas les
commettre
à ne pas croire la dernière rumeur qui
court sur les réseaux sociaux
parce qu'on va croiser les sources à
identifier peut-être 1
ethier dont on ne soupçonnait même pas
l'existence et qui pourrait nous
convenir
le deuxième principe on cherche à se
protéger à sécuriser ce qu'on sait à
maîtriser ce qu'on peut se permettre de
dire ou pas notamment sur internet
le respect de la vie privée dans les
réseaux sociaux sont devenus comme
quelque chose d'essentiel en ce moment
imaginons cet adolescent bas parce que
c'est super drôle qui s'est pris en
photo avec une cigarette un peu bizarre
à la main et camille sa photo les fesses
à l'air sur facebook sans mauvais jeu de
mots qu'est ce qu'il va se passer quand
cet adolescent va chercher un travail
quand il est passé nouvel adulte et que
l'on peut le fut son futur employeur
potentiel va taper le nom de la personne
sur internet parce que c'est ce que tout
le monde fait maintenant on tape tout
sous le nom du candidat et qui tombe sur
cette photo qu'est ce qui va se passer
ouvriers qui veulent embaucher alors ça
dépend dans quel métier mais non alors
vous allez me dire ah mais oui mais sur
facebook moi j'ai un groupe privé c'est
que entre super copain super copain d'un
jour ne rime pas avec toujours c'est pas
vrai et je peux vous garantir c'est mon
métier on trouve des trucs hallucinante
sur internet ça finit toujours pas fuité
ce genre de photos parce que justement
c'est très drôle
le prochain un besoin c'est le besoin
d'appartenance
c'est qu'on va développer un réseau réel
réseau de relations ou en ligne et
surtout apprendre à et véhiculer ses
idées et faire preuve d' influence
apprendre les techniques d influence
dans le servir dans la vie de tous les
jours pour se faire entendre et
comprendre de l'administration personne
ne rigole mais aussi auprès de sa
hiérarchie
mais pour essayer d'avoir la fameuse
promotion qu'on espérait attentes en
avoir effectivement pour cela il faut
apprendre à maîtriser sa communication
vers guerre verbale sa communication non
verbale apprend le fameux art de la
négociation mais aussi à prendre ce
qu'on appelle la communication non
violente pour éviter de blesser les
autres avec ses propos ou de se lancer
dans des conflits ou encore très
important apprendre à dire non tout en
respectant les autres
le bovin suivant les besoins d'estimé de
soi passe dans l'intelligence personnel
par la reconnaissance par le retour
d'image collègues des autres c'est à
dire notre réputation et notre
réputation sur internet alors avoir une
bonne réputation va servir de vaccin
contre les rumeurs contre vous mais ça
va nous servir aussi à rendre à créer le
climat de confiance favorable à
l'accomplissement de vos objectifs
un exemple la fameuse promotion que vous
attendiez tant est qu'on vous a pas
donné parce qu'on a estimé que vous
n'aviez pas vous n'aviez pas les épaules
assez larges pour ça et vous vous le
saviez vous étiez capable portant en
amont si vous travaillez sur votre
réputation vous fait savoir de quoi vous
êtes capables on peut éviter ou limiter
ce genre d'écueil le dernier principe
apprendre à bien gérer ses compétences
et manager ses connaissances va nous
servir dans tous les domaines que landes
village cas maintenant c'est bien pour
ça que j'ai pas rajouter un niveau
supplémentaire sur la structure jeu les
mines maya transversales comme une
colonne vertébrale c'est à ce stade que
l'on va essayer de se dépasser
que l'on va essayer par exemple de
trouver une autre voie pour son
épanouissement qu'on fait le bilan de ce
qu'on sait faire et on se compte de ce
qu'on sait pas faire pour s'améliorer
qu'on identifie bas peut-être pourquoi
pas un métier qui qui correspondait plus
à ces valeurs qui une entreprise qui
correspondait plus à ses valeurs
l'objectif c'est de partir le matin sans
la boule au ventre ne devaient pas finir
en berne atteint alors bien évidemment
tout comme matelot nous l'expliqué ici
il convient de suivre
enfin il n'est pas nécessaire de suivre
exactement cet ordre là il faut
travailler en parallèle manière globale
sur tous ces principes là mais on a
quand même on a quand même là un ordre à
peu près logique dans lequel enchaîné
tous ces différents principes
par exemple on va pas commencer à se
préoccuper de sa réputation
ça paraît logique si on n'a pas commencé
à interagir avec les autres sinon cette
réputation elle s'implique auprès de qui
est avant d'interagir avec les autres il
faut bien avoir d'abord savoir ce qu'on
peut se permettre de dire ou pas et pour
savoir quoi dire ou pas et comment le
feu
r il faut maîtriser la recherche
d'informations accumulé accusé de
l'information via la veille la veille
c'est vraiment la base de tout c'est ce
qui va nous permettre de nous informer
et de nous autres formes et dans tous
ses grands principes là alors tout ça
c'est bien beau mais à quoi ça sert de
vouloir atteindre des sommets
si c'est pour se retrouver tout seul rue
de la montagne mais ses choix la coque
ses choix que l'on prend ils vont pas
s'appliquer qu'à soi-même
ils vont s'appliquer à ses proches à sa
famille à ses amis qu'on va conseiller
plus justement et donc par effet boule
de neige qui vont servir à améliorer la
société
sans parler d'un choix plus conscient de
son bulletin de vote sans aucune
transition ni aucune allusion
certains savent utiliser l'information
pour nous manipuler
mais en maîtrisant la recherche
d'informations pour distinguer le vrai
du faux et en connaissant nous mêmes ces
différentes techniques
alors non pas pour les utiliser mais
pour se défendre et pour garantir la
liberté de ses choix
nous ne pouvons que devenir de meilleurs
citoyens alors tout tous ses principes
et a devancé nul est renseigné le plus
tôt possible à l'école je sais que
certains enseignants le font de manière
intuitive et un peu leur manière mais
c'est malheureusement c'est pas une
généralité
arrêtons dès maintenant de nous faire
manipuler
eh oui ne prenons pas le risque en fin
de vie de regretter de ne pas avoir fait
les bons choix dans l'histoire de
l'humanité on n'a jamais eu accès à
autant d'un coup de connaissances et
d'informations une manière aussi facile
mais qu'est ce que l'on fait de tout ça
c'est pas un secours malheureusement
c'est que l'avenir de la planète est
menacée et je dis pas qu'il soit
nécessaire d'inventer de nouvelles
choses pour essayer de limiter la casse
il ya déjà plein de bonnes idées pleins
de bonnes initiatives qui mériterait
d'être déployé à grande échelle mais
encore faut-il les identifier ces
initiatives
c'est là qu'intervient la veille encore
faut-il les faire savoir c'est là
qu'interviennent influence
l'idée derrière tout ça c'est de pas
réinventer la roue et de perdre du temps
comme j'en ai perdu pendant mon doctorat
à propos tend d'ailleurs j'ai mis un bon
moment dans mon côté a accepté d'être
diagnostiqué agoraphobe et donc de
pouvoir envisager de me guérir
ne faisons pas la même erreur et prenons
tous conscience dès maintenant que nous
sommes tous ici présents de grands
malades de l'information et à ce moment
là pour nous guérir
que diriez vous de suivre une thérapie
comportementale qui pourrait s'appeler
je sais pas moi l'intelligence personnel
par exemple
merci de votre attention
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]